schnallen sie sich besser an denn es
erwarten sie haar sträubende aufnahmen
ob reingefahren oder platt gemacht
haarscharf vorbei
oder mittenrein
kleine kameras auf dem armaturenbrett
sogenannte des camps zeichnen gnadenlos
alles auf
in vielen ländern boomt der markt für
base camps die aufnahmen sollen bei
unfällen als beweismittel dienen und vor
betrügern schützen die abkassieren
wollen
kein wunder also dass immer mehr
verblüffende videoclips im umlauf sind
halten sie sich gut fest wir starten
unsere reise um die welt mit bürgern die
ihnen garantiert den atem rauben werden
los geht's das sind die spektakulärsten
des camps und keine sorge
niemand wird hier ernsthaft verletzt
auch wenn es manchmal knapp wird
richtig knapp in dieser folge treffen
wir auf kängurus
[Musik]
kommen tornados gefährlich nah
und stoßen auf strunz blöder autofahrer
[Applaus]
das ist ein tornado
ist die klimaerwärmung schuld oder ist
dass der zorn gottes
warum dieser riesen wirbel
wenn so ein tornado auf zieht sollte man
nicht lange diskutieren sondern
schnellstens abbauen
riesenwirbel gibt es in den usa
besonders häufig sowohl in der politik
als auch in der natur
darum gibt es dort auch richtige
spezialisten sogenannte sturmjäger diese
verrückten typen jagen kreuz und quer
durch die usa den wirbelstürmen
hinterher um bei jedem tornado auch
wirklich in der ersten reihe zu sitzen
ist das besonders mutig oder besonders
blöd
diese jungs jagen in nebraska einen
gewaltigen watch tobago hinterher er ist
so breit wie hoch
ein solcher tornado kann ein großes
gebäude bis aufs fundament wegreißen
hier sieht man wie die trümmer durch die
luft gewirbelt werden so ein tornado ist
stark genug um einen 20 tonnen schweren
eisenbahn waggons von den schienen zu
heben
das mit dem zu glauben sie mir nicht
sehen sie den kampf der giganten
zug gegen
an dieser südafrikanischen schönheit
sieht man wunderbar wie der trichter aus
den sturmwolken hinunter zieht um auf
der erde chaos und zerstörung
anzurichten tornados üben eine
hypnotische anziehungskraft auf manche
menschen aus weshalb immer wieder
autofahrer gebannt auf sie zu steuern
anstatt einfach umzudrehen übrigens
tornados bewegen sich gewöhnlich mit 50
bis 115 stundenkilometern
willkommen in china ein gewaltiger sturm
rollt auf uns zu und so sieht das ganze
dann kurze zeit später aus
lkws und autos liegen über die strasse
verstreut als hätte ein kleinkind sie
aus einem kinderwagen geschmissen so
junge
[Musik]
und das ist ein süßes australischer baby
tornado eine sogenannte windhose
ein auto kann die nicht umwerfen
höchstens ein paar hosen von der
wäscheleine reichen
rast
diese neugierigen australier halten an
um noch bessere aufnahmen zu bekommen
ja ihr habt ein richtig großes video
gemacht herzlichen dank
[Musik]
vorsicht tiere auf der straße
bis tiere endlich ihre eigenen autos
bauen und fahren können werden sie wohl
weiter zu fuß auf unseren straßen
herumlaufen dieser schräge vogel hätte
doch auch einfach ein paar meter höher
fliegen können
filmreife reaktion
vorbildlich dagegen diese
verkehrsteilnehmer sie bilden beim
überqueren der straße ordentlich eine
reihe
nichts treibt den puls so schnell hoch
wie ein plötzlicher adrenalinstoß ein
unerwartetes niveau mit einem känguru
da hat der motorradfahrer noch mal glück
gehabt so ein speed date geht selten gut
aus
nasse fahrbahn und ein reh und ein
graben
und nun
warum kommt dieses auto plötzlich ins
schleudern
aha noch mal schwein gehabt oder
vielleicht doch nicht
immerhin ist das entlaufene schweinchen
unverletzt geblieben
stockender verkehr ja das kostet zeit
und nerven bis letztere jemandem
durchgehend gegen solche idioten sollten
sie immer den rückspiegel im auge
behalten
dass werden diese süßen kleinen enten
sicher später ihren freunden erzählen
auf amerikanischen straßen passieren
jedes jahr über eine million wildunfälle
in atlanta ist dieser profi radfahrer
gerade beim training als ihm dieses reh
vors rad springen
er hat keine chance zu reagieren
zu seinem glück hatte es kein geweih
wenn es sich doch um ein tier mit geweih
handelt sollten sie besser einen helm
und lederkleidung tragen
weiß wedel hirsche sind im
straßenverkehr unberechenbar
ehrlich so ein tweet jackett ist er für
einen ausritt oder für die fuchsjagd
geeigneten zum glück geht es dem hirsch
gut und dem elegant gekleideten herrn
auch
[Musik]
leider werden auch immer wieder tiere
angefahren
er wurde ein hund von einem auto
erwischt aber wie durch ein wunder ist
er wohlbehalten im motorraum gelandet
es braucht nur etwas gutes zureden um
ihn da rauszubekommen
kleiner glückspilz ab heute heißt du lac
in
dieser fahrer hat alle zeit der welt
anzuhalten als vor ihm wild wechselt
wie elegant und anmutig diese schönen
was war das denn
gary du hast den ganzen auftritt einer
herde vermasselt
anderes thema jeder fällt mal eine
falsche entscheidung
als autofahrer treffen sie pro kilometer
bis zu 250 entscheidungen je nachdem ob
sie in der stadt auf einer landstraße
oder auf einer autobahn unterwegs sind
das sind viele momente in denen man sich
richtig
oder falsch entscheiden kann schauen wir
uns mal ein paar fehl entscheidungen an
[Musik]
beginnen wir mit dem guten alten
kreisverkehr in großbritannien biegt man
nach links in den kreisel einen der
autofahrer hier hat offenbar andere
vorstellungen
eigentlich folgt der kreis hat er einem
einfachen prinzip solange sich alle über
die richtung einig sind
[Musik]
noch ein verwirrter fahrer der sich
falsch entschieden hat genau genommen
für die falsche ausfahrt
[Musik]
keine sorge hat niemand gesehen nur
fernsehzuschauer auf der ganzen welt
wieso drumrum eiern wenn man auch drüber
fahren kann weil man mit dem bus in der
mitte stranden könnte da waren die
fahrgäste bestimmt weniger begeistert
die fahrgäste dieses busses haben
wahrscheinlich einen noch größeren
schreck bekommen als der fahrer versucht
hat das verdeck zu öffnen zum glück
wurde niemand ernsthaft verletzt
vor dem spurwechsel sollte man erstens
in den spiegel schauen zwei den blinker
setzen und drittens den schulterblick
nicht vergessen wer dazu keine lust hat
und einfach rüber zieht fährt riskant
sehr riskant
hier scheint jeder alles richtig zu
machen blinkt und vorsichtig losgefahren
doch achten sie nun auf das blaue auto
das den blinker setzt und dann nach
rechts rüberziehen ohne den polizeiwagen
zu sehen ja den polizeiwagen
erstaunlicherweise wurden die beamten
nicht verletzt
vermutlich haben sie sich aber den kerl
danach vorgeknöpft
prüfen sie immer den toten winkel sonst
könnten sie schnell mal ein auto
übersehen oder einen fußgänger oder
einen bus dann bitte umgehend in den
rückspiegel sehen denn sie könnten einen
mitfahrer verloren haben auch hier wurde
niemand ernsthaft verletzt das resultat
waren ein paar kratzer und der feste
vorsatz sich ab jetzt immer
anzuschnallen
das ist ein klassisches beispiel von
raus fahren ohne richtig nach links und
rechts zu gucken dem 18-jährigen fahrer
bleibt keine zeit zu reagieren
das ergebnis ein ziemlich kaputtes auto
und ein fall für den schrottplatz
wer zögert der verliert
oder ist einfach nur ein idiot der einen
dämlichen utah machen wollte
[Musik]
hier läuft alles geordnet könnte man
meinen
[Musik]
aber was ist das ein polizist der sich
an das dach eines fluchtwagens klammert
das nennen wir vollen einsatz
bleiben sie auf ihrer spur
man hat viel zeit und gehirnschmalz in
den bau und die beschilderung von
straßen investiert
normalerweise funktionieren sie auch
ganz gut aber wenn diese clowns
unbedingt aus der reihe tanzen müssen
kann es ganz schön ins auge gehen oder
eben in die häuserwand
[Musik]
essen sie gerne in restaurants oder
parken sie lieber darin
vielleicht hatte diese autofahrer die
parkplatzsuche satt oder er dachte es
sei ein drive-in
wie auch immer in diesem lokal würde
wohl keinen tisch mir kriegen immerhin
kann man jetzt hier an der frischen luft
die nieren
auch dieser fahrer scheint das prinzip
von drive-in nicht verstanden zu haben
oder war das essen so schlecht
[Musik]
dieser fahrer will eigentlich nur
auspacken
nein da steht ein auto
vorsicht es steht immer noch da
ok versuchen wir es anders
[Musik]
also zurück in die forschung
jetzt zu hotels dieser gast hat
vergessen seinen zimmerschlüssel
abzugeben
ohne eine sekunde zu zögern kommt er
zurück direkt in die hotellobby um ihn
an der rezeption zu hinterlegen und
schon ist er wieder auf dem weg nach
draußen wobei er die drehtüren mit net
die handtücher hat er immerhin da
gelassen
sauer auf den staat lust macht dampf
abzulassen oder wollen sie ihre
steuererklärung nur persönlich abgeben
nicht vergessen big brother sieht alles
[Musik]
neuerdings sind hier hippe medien mamis
zu hause
vermutlich wird der kleine noah gabriel
heute zu spät zum kinderyoga kommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
endlich eine freie landstraße keine
störenden gebäude in sicht
game over jetzt am besten entspannt
zurücklehnen und richtung offenes meer
treiben lassen
die scheibenwischer könnten sie jetzt
auch ausstellen
unfall
welcher unfall
manche leute leben in ihrer ganz eigenen
welt andere wollen ihre fehler nicht
eingestehen
erst wollen sie unbedingt im mittelpunkt
stehen dann machen sie lieber schnell
einen abgang
[Musik]
dieser mann spazierte seelenruhig mit
seinem regenschirm über die straße
wie er beinahe von dem lkw geköpft wird
kriegt er kaum mit was lernen wir daraus
man braucht fernöstliche gelassenheit
und einen regenschirm
einige von uns kennen diesen zustand
trotz blessuren macht man einfach weiter
ist ja nur ein kratzer
stimmt das fällt ja wirklich kaum auf
ein wunder dass dieser lkw noch fährt
der fahrer trägt einen motorradhelm für
den fall dass der rest über ihn
zusammenbricht
[Musik]
mit etwas peter film hält das ding schon
manche menschen machen lieber keine
große sache draus
so auch hier stille auftritt von rechts
zusammenstoß mit dem auto packen
bescheidene abgang links kein drama
das hier ist spektakulär aber eigentlich
ähnlich
ein mann fährt seinen wagen zu schrott
indem er ungebremst in eine tankstelle
gerast
er steigt aus durchs fenster
totalschaden was nun einen notruf
absetzen oder das nächste taxi nehmen
als wäre nichts gewesen
doch der taxifahrer will nichts mit dem
mann zu tun haben und fährt los obwohl
sich der arme an die tür klammert heute
ist einfach nicht sein tag
schnee eis und betrunkene fußgänger die
unkontrolliert durch den verkehr wanken
der perfekte cocktail für einen unfall
ich nehme das was er hatte gerührt und
geschüttelt aber danach gehe ich nicht
auf die straße
[Musik]
ein auto rast in ein mit gemüse
beladenes motorrad
ein klassischer verfolgungsjagd stand á
la hollywood
nur ohne verfolgungsjagd aber das opfer
reagiert ganz anders als in den filmen
an statt zu fluchen und schimpfen steht
die angefahrene frau auf und sammelt ihr
gemüse wieder ein für eine suppe geht
vielleicht noch
wunder gibt es immer wieder
manchmal fragen wir uns ob es eine
höhere macht gibt wir suchen nach
zeichen nach einem beweis dafür dass wir
teil eines göttlichen plans sind
wir hatten das glück einige wunder mit
besch games einzufangen
[Musik]
seit diesen erlebnissen glauben all
diese menschen an schicksal oder an
schutzengel
ein vater sitzt rum und tippt eine
nachricht auf seinem handy während seine
süße tochter neben ihm spielt bis sie
neugierig los tat um ein bisschen die
gegend zu erkunden
zum glück folgt der vater seiner tochter
es heißt ja neugier ist der katze tot
in dem fall hat sie beide gerettet
allerdings nicht die katze denn da war
keine katze
dieses des cam auto scheint eine gute
geschwindigkeit drauf zu haben doch
einem taxifahrer ist es nicht schnell
genug
er saust vorbei gerät auf blitzeis und
kommt ins schleudern
ein heftiger crash
doch oh wunder der typ hat sich nicht
angeschnallt er wird aus dem wagen
katapultiert und ist im nu wieder auf
den beinen noch bevor er sein auto zum
stehen kommt
[Musik]
beobachten sie mal wie gewissenhaft
dieser straßenreiniger seiner arbeit
nachgeht
dieser job ist nicht ganz ungefährlich
wie man hier blut sehen kann
auch wenn man es kaum glauben kann der
unfall ist glimpflich ausgegangen
der straßenreiniger wurde nur leicht
verletzt
deshalb musste er das ganze auch noch
sauber machen
aus der entfernung fällt einem nichts
besonderes auf regen sobald man aber
näher heranzoomt ist es eine ganz andere
geschichte
dass diese drei leute von einem lkw
überfahren werden und über leben gleicht
einem wunder man kann ihre schutzengel
schimpfen hören wie kann man nur einen
lkw schneiden zu dritt auf einem scooter
auch hier hat jemand richtig glück ein
lkw beat an einer kreuzung rechts ab
ohne den fahrradfahrer neben sich zu
bemerken der mann wird unter den lkw
gezogen sein rat wird zermalmt aber er
selbst landet zwischen den riesigen
reifen
[Musik]
noch erstaunlicher ist dass er sofort
aufsteht und dem lkw hinterher rennen
will knapp in der man fertig um spottet
ein fahrrad und will dann abbauen
oder setz dich erst mal hin
ein kleines mädchen krabbelt aus einem
kindersitz und macht einen
unkonventionellen abgang durch die
kofferraumklappe zum glück passiert das
ganze als der minivan an einer ampel
hält so kommt die kleine mit einer beule
und ein paar blauen flecken davon
wir verabschieden uns mit ein paar
klicks mit sehr teuren autos die wohl
für viel geld repariert werden müssen
[Musik]
das nicht los
bis zum nächsten mal bei abgefahren die
spektakulärsten base camps